there is the conditioned self and there
is true self there is the mind and
identity and there is Spirit what we've
come to identify as who we are is
actually the construction of the Mind
the mind has created an identity we
enter this world and then the mind is
trying to understand who am I what does
that mean who are you what is this world
how do they all fit together and it
creates an identity and it builds one
and it builds certain understandings of
the world and what people do and
intentions and it's mapping out this
internal world and that is down to the
accident for birth that is down to like
you're saying you know your family your
cultural experiences the place and time
in this universe that we have this
opportunity the mind will always do that
then there is true self which is just
Consciousness and the nature of
Consciousness is love